extremists Republican senator Ted Cruz
debated his Democratic challenger beto
or Roarke last night and hilariously
when he was asked a question about
civility he snapped at the moderator and
told him to stop interrupting which is
not particularly civil especially if
you're being asked about civility and I
we're gonna play the audio for you not
the video because I'll tell you why in a
second but I want to talk about civility
a little bit civility is sort of like
tribalism it's become one of these
phrases that is popular in American
politics and is applied everywhere to
the point of being totally meaningless
and we're actually gonna do a piece on
so-called tribalism pretty soon
tribalism now is like the in vogue fad
explanation for everything in politics
there's a whole movement of so-called
analysts who will do supposedly fair and
unbiased analyses of political events
and issues and they will say tribalism
tribalism is the explanation for this
conflict or for that conflict and of
course tribalism is a factor in human
lives but it's become really trendy to
talk about tribalism as if it explains
every situation when in reality it
doesn't and it also doesn't propose any
solutions and we really need to be
looking for solutions so that's
tribalism analogously civility is
similar and you'll notice that after
Donald Trump brought to politics
everything from making fun of disabled
reporters and ridiculing the parents of
dead military service members to calling
people horse-faced on Twitter and saying
some women are simply too unattractive
for him to have sexually assaulted them
there were people on the Left who were
understandably outraged and then
immediately the right starts talking
about the importance of civility and
tone and it's basically meaningless at
this point especially when the people
calling for civility defend the guy who
did all the stuff that I just mentioned
to you so anyway we get to yesterday's
debate between Ted Cruz and better
O'Rourke and Cruz snaps in this
completely uncivil way when he's asked
about civility and we're gonna play
audio only because I've mentioned before
professional sports leagues and local
news stations are so aggressive with
copyright on the
Internet this debate was broadcast or
sponsored by or organized by local news
I believe that if we play the video even
though we would be within our fair use
rights to do it we're gonna get slapped
with copyright claim so we're gonna just
use the audio it's unfortunate too
because it's a national race so people
all across the country want to see this
I agree so it goes so it go so anyway
here's audio of the clip of this moment
from the debate where Ted Cruz snapped
while talking about being civil you're
right that there there is a loss of
civility there is an anger there is a
rage on the far left that is really
frightening you know the images
uh-uh-uh-uh-uh oh let me answer with it
don't interrupt me Jason the images of a
left-wing mob beating on the doors of
the Supreme Court that's not good for
our country we can disagree while
treating each other with respect while
treating each other with civility stop
interrupting can't you see I'm up here
irrationally slamming Democrats for
being an uncivil mob this is a microcosm
of the entire civility politics sort of
distraction
here's another moment by the way when
Ted Cruz simply decided that he deserves
more time for no reason like there was a
there was a format to the debate where
there were initial answers and rebuttals
and a system and Ted Cruz even though
everybody had already gotten their
rebuttals just unilaterally decided he
deserves more time and fortunately the
moderator said no everybody has already
gotten all the time that they were
allocated here only one senator voted no
stood in the corner while everyone else
was at the table Ted Cruz has put his
career above the interests of Texas Ted
Cruz is for Ted Cruz let me respond to
that please which is I noticed
congressman O'Rourke said we need to
support law enforcement I think that's
striking that he says that now in a
debate because his career has been won
consistently of opposing law enforcement
indeed someone else who is here today is
detected Mike Kelly who leads the San
Antonio Police Officers Association the
directive Kelly has endorsed me and I
would note as well a hundred and seventy
one elected Texan here I think thank you
very much we have oh hold on I get a
response
but we agree we can have a second but we
agree we agreed on a 60 second sir
rebuttal if necessary and I want to make
a point on law enforcement's not places
already gotten that time that's the best
so anyway if it's civility that's the
topic here civility in and of itself
isn't anything right being civil when
the other side is advocating for the
removal of social safety nets and the
opening of the floodgates of even more
destructive inequality civility is what
they arbitrarily want to focus on and
it's really important to understand that
this civility meme is being used as a
cudgel okay
the right likes to say that the left
uses identity politics as a cudgel to
stop debate or to criticize people or 2d
platform that's exactly what the right
does with this BS civility and politics
stuff there are times for civility and
there are times where civility is less
relevant in an ideal world every
political issue would be resolved in a
civil way sure but is that at all
realistic of course not and it's a
loser's game to allow the right to use
so-called civility and tone as a cudgel
and that's exactly what they're doing
here well in his defense I think that
Ted Cruz has been quite civil because
even after Trump called him lyin Ted
over and over again yeah and called his
wife ugly and said that his dad murdered
JFK yep
Ted Cruz came around phone banks for
Donald Trump and now kisses his ass all
the time
super civil you know I would I don't
think I would be able to do that yeah
apparently Ted Cruz can do it Ted Cruz
can do it Mitt Romney is doing it after
the frog-leg debacle as we're now
colloquially calling it yeah and I guess
but better or work was being criticized
for calling Ted Cruz lyin Ted because
even though he's a Democrat Trump came
up with that and he opposed Trump I
actually I haven't heard this but it's
probably a good thing that Ted Cruz
hasn't been calling Beto beta Beto right
because that could be that could be it
that's that's got some ring to it well
I've heard beta versus beta occurring to
Ted Cruz as always but if you don't have
to get into that stuff
what will on it what here's what I think
is important early voting starts Monday
in Texas October 22nd Monday you can
start voting for Beto or Roarke or
someone else if that's what you want
but I would vote for better auric vote
vote vote let me know that you're voting
send your pictures of you early voting
starting Monday in Texas today's program
brought to you in part by Blink accom
slash Pakman blinka is a great service
that I use all the time what they do is
they take thousands of the most popular
non-fiction books including the newest
bestsellers they condense them into
15-minute audiobooks that you can listen
to and you still get the most crucial
information and insights from each book
and I've listened to a ton of books on
blink Asst I recently checked out soccer
na mcc's by Simon Cooper we do have
after all the World Cup going on
recently we also have been talking about
BS jobs and there is a great new book of
BS jobs by David Graeber
which I listened to on bling cos they're
constantly adding new books to the
platform
you will never run out of fascinating
and critically acclaimed books to enjoy
and our audience can get a 7 day free
trial by going to blink Escom slash
Pakman if you're watching on YouTube I'm
putting a link in the video description
and after the free trial if you like it
you can continue enjoying thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about 5 bucks a
month that's be Li NK is t.com /pa k mas